có thể ra vàng sẽ bất kích tục tăng trong thời gian sắp tật.
Một giọng là chúng ta chú biết ra vàng sẽ đi về đâu trong nằm tới.
Nhưng mà chúng ta thấy rằng những cái lực mà kéo rất vàng xuống chạng hạn như cuộc thương chiến của thế hạ dạ.
Giồi người ta giữ chữ nên vàng Mỹ có thể sẽ lý trị lại sất thay vị,
là hãy sốt.
Và bên cạnh đó thì có thể nình tin đế của Mỹ sẽ hồi cuộc mật tốt đẹp hơn.
Vẹp Mỹ chỉ có biết đống cửa sẽ được giải quyết vào sẽ được mạo cửa.
Trong thời gian sắp tất cả những cái điều đó,
tại những cái điều mật có thể làm ordn力 chiến trường vàng phập chi lật kéo dạ vàng xuống.
Chúng ta như mọi thứ được phần đại lên thì bất kòn nó.
Trong nó có cuộc chú trảnh tạng.
Trong nó, chúng ta đẹp mật quân của Mỹ,
có sẽ còn trái dạng trong 4 năm tới trước khu khỏi là chỉ có tạy khơi đẹp này mặt bột.
Và các bạn đẹp khi tế của Mỹ sẽ đi vào một cái dạy rõ.
Có rất nhiều những viên động và tạm biệt nơi.
Tối chưa nhìn thấy một cái giống hiểu gì là cấp ninh hàng,
chủ nghĩa tên đởi sẽ tử vò, cái việc mạo qua vàng và hãy tạy hò.
Mở các nha đồ tui trên thế giới,
cũng bất vòm vàng dư là một nơi chú ở tại trị,
ăn toàn chất cấp của ngoảng khi để có thể đá phạm dạc.
Bất kích tục tăng cho một người dạy xác xác xác.